[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24
jornada de manifestaciones en rusia en
apoyo al líder opositor alexéi navalni
actualmente detenido por las autoridades
de ese país miles de personas pese a las
bajas temperaturas se tomaron las calles
de 96 ciudades de la federación más de
300 personas en ciudad restadas
en la semana del 8 de febrero tendrá
lugar el inicio del juicio político
contra el expresidente de eeuu donald
trump así lo dio a conocer el líder de
la bancada demócrata en el senado chuck
schumer 67 votos de un total de 100 son
necesarios para condenar al ex
mandatario por su papel en la toma el
capitolio el pasado 6 de enero
el laboratorio astrazéneca ha informado
a la unión europea que tendrá un recorte
de hasta el 60 por ciento en el número
de dosis pactadas para entregar en el
primer trimestre del año debido a
problemas en la producción un duro golpe
al bloque europeo que intenta avanzar
con los planes de vacunación de los 27
estados miembros que ya habían sido
afectados por los retrasos de la
farmacéutica pfiezer
muy buenos días bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález vamos a comenzar en rusia este
país vive una jornada de manifestaciones
en apoyo al líder opositor alexéi
navalni cientos de personas en unas 96
ciudades del país participan en estas
concentraciones pese a las bajas
temperaturas los ciudadanos han salido a
las calles para rechazar la detención de
naval ni el político opositor
recientemente regresó a rusia después de
recuperarse en alemania del
envenenamiento que sufrió con un agente
tóxico derivado del novillo que hasta el
momento la policía rusa ha confirmado
que más de 300 personas han sido
arrestadas y hay un blindaje total del
centro de la capital la ciudad de moscú
en donde unas 4000 personas participan
en estas marchas
rodrigo se da no tiene más detalles
cientos de seguidores del opositor
alexéi navalni detenidos desde la
primera hora de la mañana en toda rusia
ni el frío extremo del invierno ni la
anunciada presencia policial frenaron
este sábado las multitudinarias
manifestaciones a favor de la libertad
de navalny convocadas en decenas de
ciudades de todo el país en el oriente
ruso estas manifestaciones ya
desembocaron en cientos de detenciones y
enfrentamientos con la policía en
jabárovsk una de las primeras ciudades
en sumarse a las convocatorias unos 300
manifestantes exigieron la liberación
del opositor al tiempo que protestaron
por la crítica realidad en la que viven
pues los precios están subiendo todo
está subiendo mira cómo están viviendo
las regiones y como moscú mira cómo
viven allí al otro lado de los urales y
luego ven aquí y mira como la gente vive
en los pueblos la televisión dice una
cosa pero luego echa un vistazo a tu
alrededor
en moscú donde está convocada la más
grande de las marchas se registraron por
lo menos 100 arrestos antes del inicio
de las mismas
alexéi navalni fue arrestado el pasado
domingo después de aterrizar en rusia
tras haberse recuperado en alemania- del
envenenamiento con un agente tóxico
soviético el pasado agosto podría
enfrentar hasta tres años y medio de
prisión por supuestamente haber
incumplido las condiciones de una pena
dictada en 2014 tras su arresto estará
en prisión al menos hasta el 15 de
febrero
putin ha negado tajantemente las
acusaciones que apuntan a su vinculación
con el envenenamiento de su principal
opositor y en otros temas el juicio
político contra el expresidente de eeuu
donald trump comenzará la semana del 8
de febrero así lo ha comunicado el líder
de la bancada demócrata en el senado
chuck schumer sólo dos días después de
que yo badén asumiera el cargo de
presidente de eeuu para qué trompa
reciba una condena por su papel en la
insurrección del pasado 6 de enero en la
ciudad de washington son necesarios 67
votos de los 100 integrantes del senado
ya no hay vuelta atrás donald trump
afrontará su segundo juicio político a
partir de la semana del 8 de febrero ya
fuera de la casa blanca' acusado de
incitar el ataque que tuvo lugar en el
capitolio el 6 de enero
chuck schumer líder de la mayoría
demócrata en el senado ha dado a conocer
todos los detalles de un proceso con el
que pretenden pasar página
insisto todos queremos dejar este
horrible capítulo de la historia de
nuestra nación en el pasado pero la
sanación y la unidad sólo pueden existir
si hay verdad y rendición de cuentas y
eso es lo que este juicio proveerá
tienes watt de straw
el próximo lunes 25 los líderes de la
cámara de representantes- leerán los
artículos del impeachment mientras el
martes serán escogidos los senadores que
actuarán como fiscales en este juicio a
partir de este momento las partes
involucradas tendrán hasta el día del
inicio del proceso para presentar sus
defensas legales son necesarios 67 votos
a favor de los 100 miembros del senado
para que trump sea condenado y ahora
mismo la cámara alta- está dividida a
partes iguales entre ambas formaciones
con el voto
de desempate en manos de la
vicepresidenta harris aunque los
republicanos tienen una responsabilidad
doble en este proceso el futuro en el
trump está en las manos de los
republicanos son los republicanos los
que tienen que decidir si quieren que el
futuro del partido siga siendo dirigido
por la figura del trump así que se
encuentra el partido en una situación
donde pueden condenar y liquidar a trump
de cualquier futuro político tuvieran
que tener un segundo voto si es
condenado un segundo modo que con la
mayoría de uno será el harían falta 51
votos en el senado le prohibiría el
presidente de ocupar un cargo federal en
el futuro
de ser hallado culpable se convertiría
en el primer presidente de eeuu en ser
condenado tras un juicio político en un
aparente tono de cordialidad los
presidentes de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador y de estados unidos joe
biden sostuvieron una primera
conversación telefónica en la que
hablaron de temas binacionales ambos
mandatarios acordaron fortalecer y
también estrechar la colaboración entre
sus gobiernos coincidieron en que la
solución para el fenómeno de la
migración radica en el desarrollo de las
comunidades de origen al tiempo que
conversaron también sobre temas
relacionados con el intercambio
comercial méxico y eeuu tienen una
estrecha y también muy dependiente de
relación mercantil que se vio
entorpecida por las exigencias impuestas
por la antigua administración de donald
trump
el general en retiro lloyd austin fue
confirmado por el senado de eeuu como
nuevo secretario de defensa
austin se convierte así en el primer
afroamericano en ser jefe del pentágono
en 41 años de carrera militar rompió
varias barreras raciales y ocupó un
lugar clave en la campaña militar de
eeuu en irak durante la presidencia de
barack obama su nombramiento no está
exento de las dudas debido a que viene
de ocupar la junta directiva de uno de
los principales contratistas del
pentágono el informes de federico cue
barberena
ingresa al pentágono como el primer
afroamericano en liderar lo lloyd austin
fue confirmado por el senado como
secretario de defensa en una decisión
bipartidista casi unánime a su cargo
estará un controvertido presupuesto de
750.000 millones de dólares militar
durante 41 años el general retirado
prometió respetar el control civil de
las fuerzas armadas
y la seguridad de nuestra democracia
exige un control civil competente de
nuestras fuerzas armadas la
subordinación del poder militar al civil
pase toda mi vida comprometido con ese
principio
en su carrera hostil rompió barreras
raciales como sede primer afroamericano
en liderar el comando central unidad
responsable de las operaciones en medio
oriente durante la presidencia de barack
obama fue una cara visible de las
operaciones en irak y de la lucha contra
el estado islámico pero su nombramiento
también ha despertado dudas por un lado
no cumplía la norma de llevar siete o
más años retirado de la fuerza por lo
que debió recibir un permiso del
congreso por otra parte antes de su
llegada al gabinete de
en ocupaba la junta de directores de
reid en una de las principales
contratistas del pentágono e implicada
en la venta de insumos militares a
naciones como arabia saudita que los
utilizó en la guerra en yemen es
importante que el secretario de defensa
lleve a ese papel una independencia de
pensamiento y es muy preocupante cuando
un nominado proviene directamente de uno
de los principales contratistas
militares para calmar las dudas
austin aceptó duplicar de dos a cuatro
años el periodo de recusación sobre la
toma de decisiones que involucren al rey
de ons y se comprometió a no volver a
trabajar en una empresa de defensa o
como cabildero cuando deje su cargo en
otros temas el laboratorio astrazéneca
ha informado oficiales europeos de un
recorte de hasta un 60% en las dosis
pactadas para entregar en el primer
trimestre del año debido a problemas en
la producción este es un duro golpe para
el bloque comunitario donde avanzan allí
las campañas de inoculación que ya
fueron afectadas también por los
retrasos registrados en las entregas de
la farmacéutica pfiezer a principios de
enero la agencia europea de medicamentos
permitió a los profesionales de la salud
extra
de cada vial 6 dosis de la vacuna contra
el joven y 19 desarrollada por esta
farmacéutica lo que se puede traducir en
un jugoso negocio veamos
después de la reciente aprobación de la
agencia europea de medicamentos ahora
son 615 las dosis de la vacuna de facer
contra el cob y 19 que se están
extrayendo de cada vial pero a las
enfermeras de este centro de vacunación
les ha resultado complicado exprimir la
sexta dosis
si la persona que prepara la vacuna está
distraída o estresada tal vez podría
cometer un error y eso podría afectar a
la cantidad de dosis que sacamos del
vial de godó el gmail hecho botox y
meses porque seis dosis significa que
estamos usando toda la vacuna en el
vídeo son 100 mililitros hate extraer
una sexta dosis ha permitido a fayza
reducir de 120 millones a 100 millones
el número de viales entregadas a la
unión europea sin dejar de cumplir su
compromiso de 600 millones de dosis en
un comunicado pzifer dijo que está
respetando su calendario de entregas y
que el cambio no tendrá ningún impacto
en el desarrollo de la vacunación pero
podría ser una fuente de ingresos para
el gigante farmacéutico
a unos doce euros por dosis la reventa
de las 20 millones de viales adicionales
podrían generarle a la empresa 1500
millones de euros extra
si el contrato se vendió por dosis y no
por frascos entonces no hay nada que
digas de facer no ha respetado su
obligación contacto
faisal podría enfrentarse a la presión
de italia miembro de la unión europea
que ha prometido demandar al fabricante
de medicamentos además de los problemas
registrados con pzifer astrazéneca
anunció a la unión europea un recorte de
hasta el 60 por ciento en la entrega de
sus vacunas durante el primer trimestre
los retrasos llevaron a hungría a
convertirse en el primer país de la
unión en comprar un fármaco distinto
tras aprobar la vacuna rusa a
continuación otras noticias destacadas
del día quién france24
llegó a brasil el primer lote de 2
millones de dosis de vacunas contra el
cob y 19 elaborado por la dupla oxford
astrazéneca este primer envío llega a
este país suramericano con una semana de
retraso por lo que las autoridades
brasileñas pusieron en marcha el plan de
vacunación con 6 millones de dosis de la
vacuna china sinovac
el gobierno de la república oriental del
uruguay anunció que cerró acuerdos de
compra de vacunas elaboradas por los
laboratorios pzifer y sinovac aunque no
dio a conocer la cantidad de dosis ni
tampoco cuando comenzara el plan de
inmunización
el anuncio llega cuando uruguay batió su
récord diario de fallecidos con 17
víctimas y también al contabilizar mil
186 nuevos casos
bogotá la capital colombiana con cerca
de 8 millones de habitantes comienza el
fin de semana en su tercera jornada de
confinamiento riguroso en lo que va
corrido del año la medida impuesta por
las autoridades locales se extenderá
hasta la madrugada del lunes y busca
disminuir la incidencia de casos de
contagio de kobe 19 la capital
colombiana registra una ocupación del 92
por ciento de las unidades de cuidado
intensivo
la ciudad de wuhan en china con unos 11
millones de habitantes y lugar de origen
del coronavirus cumplió un año del
inicio del confinamiento general después
de declararse allí la emergencia
sanitaria ahora mientras la pandemia se
extiende por el mundo entero bojan ha
vuelto prácticamente a la normalidad
nuestro corresponsal adrián foncillas
desdibujan nos da más detalles en el
siguiente reporte
o se cumple un año desde que usan
ordenar a su confinamiento una medida
sin precedentes y que fue recibida por
el mundo con críticas de escepticismo
pero que poco después tuvo que replicar
los once millones de ugandeses tuvieron
que permanecer durante 76 días
encerrados en sus casas sin posibilidad
de pisar la calle bajo ninguna excusa
porque una red extensa de funcionarios y
voluntarios les llevaban la comida y
todo lo que pudieran necesitar o johan
cumple ocho meses sin contagios locales
y disfruta de algo muy parecido a la
vieja normalidad con bares y
restaurantes llenos aquí se dice que
esta es la ciudad más segura de china y
que además cuentan con experiencia así
que si el virus reaparece sabrán cómo
vencerlo de nuevo y sin embargo nadie
baja la guardia que todo el mundo lleva
mascarillas y en los locales siguen
pidiendo el código verde en el teléfono
no preocupa ahora a wuhan sino el brote
localizado en pekín y las provincias
limítrofes es el más grave de los
últimos meses y está poniendo en peligro
la celebración de
vacaciones de año nuevo y seguimos en
china porque en la ciudad de hong kong
unas 9000 personas de los barrios de
jordania y de yau ma tei en el distrito
de coulón comenzarán un confinamiento
estricto impuesto por las autoridades
locales por espacio de 48 horas estas
zonas estarán totalmente aisladas las
personas deben permanecer en sus hogares
y serán sometidas a pruebas obligatorias
esto como parte del esfuerzo de las
autoridades hongkonesas para contener el
incremento en los casos de kobe 19
asimismo el gobierno también anunció el
otorgamiento de una serie de subsidios
para quienes den positivo en estas
pruebas de kobe 19 y residan en estos
distritos
punto final en la noticia de france 24
siga con nuestra programación buenos
días
[Música]